If you're displaying dynamic content
where you don't know the exact size it
will be or
when handling different size devices,
it can be useful to display
the image at a fixed aspect ratio.
So you know how your design
will appear for your users.
We've already covered using
scale type such as center crop,
to make the content fit
within an image view.
But how do we enforce
the size of the view itself?
To do this, we can easily subclass image
view to enforce a given aspect ratio.
Let's walk through an example of always
wanting our images to show with a 3:2
aspect ratio.
That is whatever width its given,
will set its own height
to be two-thirds of this.
Let's create a new class and
we're calling it 3:2 image view here.
And will extend from ImageView itself.
Now, we'll generate all of
the required constructors to
handle create this view from code or
from XML.
Now the key part,
let's override the onMeasure method.
We'll unpack the width we're given,
and then calculate two-thirds of this.
As the threeTwoHeight.
We'll then say that our view's
height wants to be exactly
that two-thirds of the width height.
We then pass these onto
the superclass to handle the rest
of the measurement class.
To use our custom class, we use our
fully qualified name in the tag and
follow the convention
setting 0dp as the height.
As this declared value isn't used,
but has to be provided.
And the view itself will then calculate
height later on when it measures itself.
This is similar to how we used weights
in lesson one to fill the space in
a linear layout.
We set 0dp as the unused size because
the weight would fill it in later.
We'll go into much more detail
on altering your lay out for
different size devices in lesson five.